[Music]
memes are all the rage these days you
can't open up Instagram or Twitter
without seeing at least a few memes but
have you ever wondered where some of
those memes actually came from and what
inspired them
you'll be surprised to see with the
murdered girl looks like in real life if
this is your first time on our channel
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe for more in this video we will
unveil the truth so here's the real
story behind ten popular internet memes
toothless Drake somewhere between his
time on Degrassi and becoming arguably
one of the most popular rappers alive
Drake became a popular meme magnet his
soft hearted lyrics matched with the
fact that he was a child star made him
an easy target
the Drake meme started with a popular
image of him in a wheelchair as his
Degrassi character Jimmy with the lyrics
she said she missed the old Drake girl
don't tempt me written over it from
there it was history in fact Drake has
been a subject of so many memes that
Saturday Night Live even dedicated a
whole skit - Drake memes comedian de
soos told popular magazine noisey that
Drake is completely aware of all the
memes he started as an easy target for
memes and realized the social value of
being a piece of content this is how he
started creating photos he knew social
media would devour the toothless Drake
meme is an instant classic it fits in so
many situations one popular version of
the meme puts the word swag over
toothless Drake as if the rapper is
speaking with a-list honestly we could
look at Drake memes all day so whoever
is making them keep them coming
success kid if you haven't seen the
success kid meme then you've probably
been living under a rock the meme shows
a baby bawling up his fists in a
triumphant manner sometimes it's
referred to as I hate sandcastles meme
and is photoshopped to include another
child in the background with a destroyed
Stan Castle the meme came from a picture
taken by a Lanie Greiner of her eleven
month old son
samy in 2007 she posted on Flickr and
Getty Images in January 2008 the photo
began to spread making it too many
myspace profiles as the avatar by
February 2011 there have been over
66,000 memes made from this photo on
quick meme also 300 on meme generator
and around 3000 on the advice animals
subreddit the photo was even used in a
2012 virgin media campaign the success
kid is now 10 years old and though his
fame has died down his mother was able
to use his success to start a GoFundMe
to raise money for his father's kidney
transplant the campaign raised over
83,000 in donations and the boy's father
was able to have the procedure so all in
all sometimes we guessed it actually
pays to be a meme sensation grumpy cat
named the grumpy cat meme is one of the
most widely spread and recognizable
memes around but who is the cat behind
all the funny pictures that have us
laughing uncontrollably first you'll be
surprised to know that this is a female
her name is tartar sauce and she is a
snowshoe cat with a very angry
disposition she began to rise to stardom
after pictures of her were posted on
reddit in September of 2012 the brother
of her owner Tabitha abundance in' was
the one to originally post the photos
online the pictures immediately gained
traction and were photoshopped into
other popular memes the photos reached
the front page of Reddit with over
25,000 up votes within the first 24
hours and the I'm group age garnered
over 1 million views within 48 hours but
that wasn't the end of the memes
virility later popular websites started
sharing the picture and reddit are
cattle aides soon posted more grumpy cat
memes since grumpy cat first came on the
scene she's appeared pretty much
everywhere with Wi-Fi and the meme
doesn't seem to be losing any popularity
we certainly hope that grumpy cat never
goes away what's your favorite grumpy
cat meme of all time Michael Jordan
crying first off let us say that Michael
Jordan cry meme is
yes the amount of anguish just makes for
the perfect mean but what had basketball
superstar and sneaker tycoon Michael
Jordan all teary here's the story behind
the meme the picture was snapped back in
September 2009 by photographers Stephane
savoia when Michael Jordan was giving a
speech when being inducted into the
Basketball Hall of Fame
savoia knew that the moment was
monumental and couldn't risk passing up
the opportunity to snap the basketball
star being so emotional the picture lay
relatively dormant for years without
anyone noticing it until seemingly
overnight it turned into a meme
sensation people began using the photo
to present many different situations
Michael Jordan is well aware of his meme
Fame but word has it that he actually
isn't a fan of the meme at all some
sources believe that he hates it
but if the same any press is good press
holds true then maybe Jordan shouldn't
be so upset by the mean with his
successful shoe line and the memory of
his more than a successful career weed
out a single meme can tarnish his brand
no matter how hilarious it might be
disaster girl you know the disaster girl
made well it features a little girl in
front of a burning home staring at a
camera with a devilish look on her face
as if she caused the fire but do you
know where the photo came from the photo
was taken by Dave Roth in January of
2004 when his local fire department did
a live fire drill training near his home
in North Carolina the little girl in the
photo is Roth's daughter Zoe years would
buy and in 2007 Roth uploaded it to
zoomer with the title firestarter months
later November Roth submitted the photo
to jpg magazine for an emotion capture
competition and it was selected to be
published in the February March of 2008
issue by November of that year the
magazine's online post had gained over
95,000 views and by October it made its
way to BuzzFeed which is a sure sign of
virility since then Roth has continued
to post photos of his daughter on his
Flickr account but none have reached the
virility of the original disaster girl
photo we are just happy to know that Zoe
didn't start the fire and no one was
hurt in the making of the meme scumbag
Steve
have you seen the meme of the guy
standing in the doorway with baggy
clothes trying to look like a gangsta
chances are that you have the photo like
most viral memes was posted to Reddit
and blasted into internet fame from
there apparently the guy in the photos
real name is not Steve at all but Blake
Boston the picture was taken in 2006 by
Boston's mother when he was in a rap
group called the town mafia he posted
the photo on his myspace account which
must have caught some attention because
it was then put on reddit sends his
initial posting the photo has taken on a
life of its own and been made into an
innumerable amount of memes when he
first reached Internet stardom Boston
hated the memes and wasn't the nicest
about it but because memes live on
forever he eventually had to accept the
meme today though Boston has left his
dreams of a rap career and all scumbag
activities in the past he now works as a
chef and has a son so though we may
never get another scumbag Steve video
the meme will live in our hearts and on
our screens forever college freshmen
remember the college freshman meme the
one with the guy on his phone in a
collegiate hoodie the picture seems
unsuspected enough but once it got in
the hands of the Internet the rest was
history people began using the photo to
make fun of how naive freshman and
college are the student pictured is
Griffin Kerr itse who was a freshman at
the University of New Hampshire he had
agreed to do an interview with Reader's
Digest on the campus thinking that it
would be a quick and easy thing he
thought that it was no big deal and
posed for some pictures the photos were
used alongside articles about what it's
like to be a freshman and maintaining
your college finances and Carib dude
thought that would be the end of that
and it would have been the end had the
users of Reddit not found the photo they
turned currency into a meme that will
live on in infamy but he took the meme
an instafamous tribe in a reddit chat he
said that the memes that people made
were actually pretty spot-on
there were laundry jokes but bragging
about parties he went to and all the
dying ones that happened to him
so we think it's safe to say that he
enjoys the meme he also says that he
plans on being a freshman for the rest
of his life
ermahgerd girl you know that ermahgerd
girl meme it shows a girl with pigtails
and braces proudly clutching three books
the popular goosebumps series the
picture itself was just a meme waiting
to happen just look at the joy on the
girl's face the girl in the photo is
Maggie golden burger and she never
thought she would become a well-known
meme the photo was taken when she was 11
and she had been playing dress-up with
her friend Kailen and found the
ridiculous best that she's pictured in
she thought it would be funny to try it
on and add a nerdy backpack and put her
hair in pigtails she stuck a retainer in
her mouth and added Flair she then made
a funny face and grabbed the books and
Kailyn took the photo the photo was a
hit almost as soon as Kailyn uploaded it
to Facebook it really began to catch
steam when a 16 year old named Jeff
Davis came across it and posted it on
Reddit with the title just a book on her
smile soon others began to type new
captions on the photo and tell one
person came up with armored guard while
the photo may be embarrassing for golden
burger it gave the internet laughs for
years and she looks fine now so
everything is well that ends well bad
luck Brian Oh Brian it looks like your
luck has changed the bad luck Brian
photo has all the elements of the
perfect name it shows a kid with braces
smiling awkwardly into the camera while
wearing a tight red plaid sweater over
his shirt it's painfully awkward and
also reminiscent of all the
uncomfortable class photos we had to
take in our younger years the boy in the
picture is Kyle Craven who never
expected his seventh grade class photo
to go viral when it was originally
posted to Reddit no one cared
in fact the post got less than five
uploads but once other people began
making him into a meme he soon became a
viral sensation in 2012 the memes
usually center around Brian doing
something embarrassing to himself which
makes the meme extremely relatable
especially for anyone who has gone
through puberty being a meme hasn't been
all that for Craven he shared on a
reddit ask me anything thread that even
comedian Seth Rogen recognized him one
time later he took a play in the hand
chimes which was just a meme waiting to
be made
we wish Craven good luck in life but
can't get enough of bad luck Brian
wanted in 50 states nothing makes a
better meme than an attractive mug shot
mug shots in general our meme gold but
when the person in them is quite
good-looking
it's a meme jackpot Meghan McCullough
realized this when her mugshot made it
to the Internet she was arrested back in
2010 for driving under the influence she
had probably moved on with her life when
two years later her mugshot reemerged in
a blog spot about the most attractive
female mug shots still that fame was
short-lived and everything went back to
normal and tell a few months later when
her mug shot was uploaded to Reddit this
time it had the caption wanted in 50
states that was enough to catapult the
meme into instant notoriety
where is McCullough now well now she
goes by Meghan Simmons and says that her
meme was a wake-up call because of the
virility of it she couldn't escape her
mug shot she also says that she doesn't
believe the picture does her justice but
that didn't matter to the several men
who contacted her with marriage
proposals we are happy to see that
Simmons was able to turn things around
but we will always be thankful for the
wanted in 50 states meme and now you
know the real story behind some of your
favorite memes got any more memes you
want us to get to the root of tell us in
the comments and don't forget to give us
a thumbs up thanks for watching
[Music]
you